il faut savoir qu'apple cette année à
enterrer définitivement à supprimer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour ça y est
apple a présenté en fin à ses nouveaux
iphone pour cette année donc je vais
vous le développer d'ici quelques
secondes des histoires qu'on comprenne
vraiment qu'on voit un petit peu quels
sont les produits qu'on peut en faire
alors on va faire un petit brief complet
mais juste avant je vais vous montrer un
peu cool parce que si vous êtes comme
moi et que vous travaillez avec votre
smartphone à côté de vous il ya un
accessoire qui peut être vraiment hyper
hyper pratique qui vous permet de vous
faciliter un peu la vie ses marques et
la make it easy
c'est un accessoire de la marque easy ac
l'idée si vous voulez c'est que vous
voulez bosser tranquillement recharger
votre téléphone en même temps bâle ap en
cours vous avez un accessoire qui est
hyper cool et qui je pense pourrait vous
aider voilà ça alors vous regardez comme
ça vous dit c'est quoi ce truc
eh bien tant que c'est plutôt pas mal
parce que ça vous permet d'avoir tous
vos outils pour pouvoir bosser et en
même temps pouvoir recharger votre
téléphone en réduction sans fil et ça
c'est cool earth un pot à crayon tout
simplement donc vous prenez pour les
arrivées vous mettez tous vos crayons
dedans comme ça vous prenez votre
smartphone vous voyez là on est en led
bleue vous le prenez vous le posez dans
la couleur de la lède change elles
passent au vert et le smartphone se
rechargent derrière vous avez un petit
câble
c'est du sb vous mettez un adaptateur ça
marche très bien
c'est cool ça vous permet d'avoir un
petit accessoire de bureau avec vos
crayons votre truc vous rechargez votre
smartphone
c'est plutôt cool si vous intéresse je
vous mets tous les liens madame
description deuxième accessoires un peu
plus épais c'est une batterie de cinq
mille billions terreur vous avez le
bouton là pour checker le niveau de
batterie pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
vous prenez votre smartphone voulu
glisser dedans il vient recharger votre
smartphone directement pareil en
adduction alors là par contre c'est
vraiment pour les cas extrêmes
quand vous avez vraiment besoin de vous
déplacer ça vous fait une batterie en
plus ses batteries de 5000 et en période
on pouvait faire deux charges avec je
voulais partager ses produits parce
qu'on voit que la recharge par induction
ça développe de plus en plus ça va
continuer à se développer
donc ça c'est vraiment pour des besoins
en termes de mobilité et pour la
bureautique
vous allez le produit la sai à peu a
représenté c'est tout nouveau iphone
pour l'année 2018 le coup 2018 on voit
que l'iphone 10 aces et l'iphone dix
jours à dire c'est super dur à dire
l'iphone 10s l'iphone 10 aces et
l'iphone 10 s max sont des vraies
évolutions de l'iphone d'ici là
plusieurs points positifs c'est une
évolution n'y a rien de bien qui change
au niveau du design
si ce n'est la taille pour le dissès max
plus facile à dire tms maxon américaine
10 aces max est chaud et dire il ya une
évolution
il ya une évolution certaine on reste
néanmoins sur un aspect le même look gt
avec la surprise vient surtout de
l'iphone 10r le modèle d'entrée de gamme
low cost pour apple tout ça on va le
détail et on va regarder au final ce
qu'apportent ces nouveaux iphone
quelles sont les nouveautés quels sont
les les choses attendu qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire de mieux avec en quoi ils
sont plus cool et au final est-ce qu'il
faut les acheter oui non est ce que ça
vaut le coup ça va faire qu'on voit là
tout ça on a beaucoup parlé d' apple à
cette année parce que ça va apple donne
toujours le pouls de la tech au niveau
des smartphones sur cette présentation
on a parlé à de la nouvelle apple watch
ces risques at on va l'été dans une
autre vidéo parce que ça mérite vraiment
une autre vidéo et des choses qui sont
vraiment super pertinentes et là les
miches presque plusieurs to die est sur
la pelouse
serris 4 que sur les nouveaux ipod non
pas que je trouve pas coûte je trouve
vraiment super cool mais bon on en
reparlera donc rester connectés et
abonnez vous première nouveauté au
niveau de l'iphone 10 aces et une
certification ip67 jusqu'à une
certification ip67 ça va un peu plus
loin je dirais qu apple là d'ssus mais
au niveau par rapport aux autres
l'iphone 10 aces et l'iphone 10 s max
ont tous les deux des anticipations ip68
l'iphone 10r quant à lui à une
certification ip67 du côté de l'iphone
10 sg mais note excusez moi si je lis un
petit peu parce que j'ai pas eu le temps
tout apprendre par coeur la siac la
présentation vient de se terminer donc
je vous le fais à chaud directement
l'iphone 10s à un écran oled de 5,8
pouces là il n'y a pas de changement par
rapport au net de l'année dernière on a
une définition de 2436 par 1125 pixels 2
7 1 millions de pixels et 458 pixels par
pouce du côté de l'iphone xs nax j'y
arriverai pas ces grandes oled de 6,5
pouces une
définition de 2688 par 1242 xl 3,3
millions pixels et 458 pixels par pouce
voilà messieurs dames
du côté de l'iphone 10r vous avez un
écran de 6,1 pouces un écran lcd
ils appellent ça le liquid retina
display il a une définition de 1792 par
800 pixels à 24 me en couleur et 326
pixels par pouce au niveau des deux
modèles les plus haut de gamme vous avez
du hdr disent vous avez du dolby vision
vous avez une qualité d'écran en tout
cas sur le papier kern est vraiment au
top comme apple sait le faire avec une
vraie maîtrise de ce côté là qui nous
annonce des images 60% plus dynamique
par rapport à l'iphone dit de l'année
dernière vous êtes toujours le trou
tonnes le toucher 3d le toucher trône et
vous l'avez pas sur le 10 r c'est normal
c'est un des modèles les c'est le modèle
le moins cher non pas mettre tout leur
techno dessus néanmoins vous avez quand
même toucher à tique sur le dessus sur
tous les modèles vous avez failli saïdi
toujours plus rapide toujours plus
sécurisé
derrière il ya la nouvelle puce à 12
bionique gravé en 7 nanomètres avec pas
moins de 6 59 milliards de transistors
je vous passe et données techniques ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il est quand
même beaucoup plus rapide que la puce en
fusion et il vous permettra de faire des
économies d'énergie batteries
consommerait donc beaucoup moins avec
beaucoup plus de performances du coût
des applications qui vont se lancer
beaucoup plus rapidement à smartphone
beaucoup plus rapides beaucoup plus
intelligent grosso modo c'est ce qu'il
faut retenir
point intéressant sur les d modèle le
plus haut de gamme vous avez du son
stéréo donc un son qui va être beaucoup
plus spécialisés lorsque vous allez
regarder des vidéos on est flic sur
youtube ce que vous voulez lorsque vous
allez jouer à des jeux qui auront une
station un peu plus d'immersion il met
en avant la machine learning grâce à la
puce à 12 bionique ça permettra donc à
votre iphone de mieux comprendre ce que
vous allez faire d'anticiper vos besoin
d'aller toujours plus vite de savoir
actuellement vous allez voir une
application pour tous soit beaucoup plus
rapides beaucoup plus fluide et d'avoir
une meilleure expérience utilisateur qui
dit plus de puissance d'idées
le plus performant dit la réalité
augmentée beaucoup plus sympa comme ça
sont vraiment pas placer sur la réalité
virtuelle vraiment sur la réalité
augmentée
ils nous montrent des applications avec
des jeux qui ont l'air vraiment cool en
réalité augmentée du point de vue des
caméras
il faut savoir que sur les deux modèles
les plus haut de gamme vous avez un
double module caméra à l'arrière sur
l'iphone 10r vous avez un seul module
caméra l'arrière question coûts oblige
forcément sur les deux modèles les plus
haut de gamme c'est toujours un double
capteur photo 12 mégapixels grand-angle
12 mégapixels tel objectif
les 2 août une stabilisation optique le
téléobjectif permettra d'abord un zoom
optique x 2 et un zoom numérique x 10
sans grand temps le jeune arthur de f
1.8 dont des photos lumineuses sur le
téléobjectif une ouverture de f 2.4
lutte est l'objectif des vous servira
surtout pour aller faire des zooms et
pour le mode portrait ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que 12 mégapixels
grand-angle ouvre à f 1.8 on pourrait
presque dire uniquement à f 1.8 là où on
voit la concurrence je pense notamment à
huawei sur du pev intro ou alors
carrément à samsung avec son galaxy s 9
plus voir son galaxy note 9 ouvrir af
1.5 avoir des photos extrêmement
performante en faible luminosité
apple n'a pas du tout fait le focus sur
la qualité des photos en faible
luminosité est ce qu ils considèrent que
leur smartphone est suffisamment
performants comme ça par rapport à la
concurrence et ce qu'ils veulent
justement pas rentrer en frontal avec
les autres pour qu'on aille pas les
opposer directement à voir en tout cas
lors des phases de test et vous pouvez
les virements film et jusqu en quête cas
à 60 fps sur iphone 10r hongro vous
n'avez pas la caméra avec le thé
l'objectif
vous avez donc une 12 mégapixels
ouverture f 1.8 stabilisation optique le
croûton lui focus pixels enfin tout ça
tout ça vous allez le smart hdr le
portrait demande enfin voilà qui
permettra en tout cas de faire des
photos d'excellente qualité
quelles que soient vos appareils vous
avez à l'avant la caméra troude health
avec fayçal 10 qui fait vous avez une
caméra de 5 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.2 pouvait filmer
jusqu'en 1080p à 60 images par seconde
forcément avec le module caméra trop
d'elle c'est très logique qu'on retrouve
exactement la même chose sur les trois
modèles et il ya un point qui est
extrêmement sympa sur les deux modèles
les plus haut de gamme c'est le réglage
de l'ouverture son portrait de mode ce
qui fait que vous allez avoir un effet
boké peut être très fort
vous allez régler le fou soit très flou
jusqu'à pas floues du tout vous
choisissez ce que vous voulez en
fonction des cas ça peut être vraiment
sympa et ça c'est une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui est implémenté dans
ces deux nouveaux iphone haut de gamme
en termes d'autonomie apple aime pas du
tout communiquer sur les chiffres
vous l'avez vu sur les spécifications
techniques ça ne pas trop parler de tout
ça en tout cas se font au niveau
l'autonomie c'est que l'iphone 10,16
sort à 30 minutes de batterie en plus
par rapport à l'iphone 10 de l'année
dernière et l'iphone 10 s max 1h30 de
batterie en plus
et du côté de l'iphone 10 r on a une
comparaison qui fait avec l'iphone 8
avec une heure trente de batterie en
plus par rapport à l'économie
cela permet un petit peu de comparer les
gabbro l'iphone 10 r est une évolution
de l'iphone 8 qui en gros on prend le
look de l'iphone 10 mais reste sur un
écran lcd comme l'iphone 800 espèce de
mélange tout ça pour dire on garde un
petit peu le côté de techniques de nos
anciens iphone mais on a donc de nouveau
iphone voilà à vous de choisir après
grande nouveauté cette fois ci aux côtés
des iphone c'est l'arrivée de la double
carte sim
ça peut être intéressant pour les usages
professionnels et particuliers en même
temps ça peut aussi être sympa lorsque
vous voyagez dans un pays vous avez la
carte sim de votre pays d'origine et la
carte sim du pays dans lequel vous
voyagez ça peut aussi être sympa pour
les frontaliers enfin là c'est pas mal
d'utilisation peuvent être cool là
dessus à noter aussi qu apple s'est mis
au vert en parlant de recyclage de ses
smartphones grâce à l'apple diesbach
lorsque aux smartphones sont usagés vous
pouvez les renvoyer apple ça se monétise
et derrière il ya un vrai geste pour
l'environnement noter que pas mal de
composants intérieurs qui viennent de
produits recyclés ça c'est plutôt bien
ça donne une touche green apple et c'est
vraiment un pas positif au niveau des
iphone les plus haut de gamme vous avez
une finition or argent gris vous pouvez
précommander les deux iphone et les plus
haut de gamme à partir du 14 septembre
pour une dispo le 21 septembre pour
recevoir directement tandis que l'iphone
10r faut attendre le mois d'octobre vous
avoir précommandé le 19 octobre et
recevoir à partir du 26 octobre
bon tout ça c'est bien beau et
maintenant qu'en est il du prix l'iphone
10s en 64 giga riehl vous coûtera à 1159
euros en 256 giga 1329 euros en 512 ziga
mille 559 euros et pour avoir les
modèles max pour ajouter 100 euros de
plus sur 1064 1259 256 1429 et 512 me
659 euros quasiment
1700 euros c'est énorme alors on arrive
maintenant sur le modèle 10 erp le
modèle 10r est dispo en six couleurs
blanc noir bleu jaune corail et le
modèle raid salah le modèle règle tous
les ans apple sort un modèle raid pour
la lutte contre le sida c'est pas si on
retrouve directement là plutôt cool
parce que c'est un modèle qui est
vraiment très jolie en tout cas moi
c'est ma couleur préférée en 64 giga et
vous coûtera 859 euros tout de suite
beaucoup plus raisonnable en 128 gigant
919 et en 256 gigaoctets sliimy l'euro à
1029 euros voilà un petit peu ce qui se
passe alors il faut savoir qu à peu
cette année à enterrer définitivement à
supprimer l'adaptateur pour lightning
jack donc ce nouveau iphone vous avez
soit la possibilité d'acheter à part le
port lightning jack soit d'acheter un
casque bluetooth pour vous mettre à la
page je suis pauvre en tout cas c'est
une stratégie intéressante pour apple je
ne disais pas dans une précédente vidéo
se permet à apple de gagner en coûts de
production de réduire un petit peu le
coup directement dans ses boîtes devant
des adaptateurs
en plus de vous le facturer c'est une
stratégie qui est plutôt très très bien
ficelé et très maline l'île aux cerfs
d'autrefois qui est très intéressant
c'est que l'iphone 10 a carrément
disparu du site d'apple
vous avez maintenant vers la gamme des
iphone vous avez l'iphone 5 l'iphone 8
l'iphone 10s l'iphone 10 s max et
l'iphone 10r l'iphone 10e et dernière
n'existe plus et est l'iphone
anniversaire ils étaient remplacés par
les nouveaux modèles donc si vous voulez
acheter il va falloir le trouver
ailleurs
devant le petit peu pour ces infos sur
ses nouveaux iphone quand ces nouveaux
crus iphone de cette nouvelle année 2010
huitard bien évidemment ses iphone on va
les tester on va la garder plus en
détail dans quelques temps donc je vous
invite à vous abonner et à rester
connectés en tout cas je trouve ça
plutôt intéressant on n'est pas sûr d
grosse grosse grosse grosse révolution
on est sur une évolution gagne peut-être
comme vous savez il ya beaucoup de
marquer notamment comme apple qui
mettent des grosses révolutions une
année sur deux l'année dernière j'avais
vraiment le gros coup de fouet avec les
dix ans d'iphone avec l'arrivée d'iphone
10 cette année on a une évolution on va
l'iphone 10s l'année prochaine allez
savoir ce qu'on va voir
avoir un iphone 11 est-ce qu'on va avoir
un iphone 10 2019 je sais pas quoi c'est
en tout cas c'est super intéressant je
vous invite à vous abonner et à la
sérénité parce que on va une fois de
plus beaucoup en parler mais j'attends
vraiment
tous vos commentaires en retour en bas
pour nous dire ce que vous en pensez je
compte sur vous et à très bientôt
topo
[Musique]